he's one of my favorite people i've
gotten to meet and we met through
twitter so twitter's not a terrible
disaster pit
of misery and a cesspool it is uh filled
with nice things too
especially when it's tweeted out by this
guy what i love is rex chapman back here
in the rich hazard show how you doing
rex
hello rich how are you buddy i am better
for talking to you
uh on friday yeah same to you and
sometimes you know
uh we get lucky when we uh book somebody
like yourself and it seems like breaking
news going on on the worldwide leader in
sports right now looks like the
mavericks are finalizing a deal to make
jason kidd their next head coach what do
you think about all that
i love it that's my dude i know
jay kidd i know i i was never
as good a player before or after
playing with jason no kidding he was
he made me so much better he made
everybody so much better
uh just an amazing player i'm really
pumped for jay if this is uh
actually this is actually true uh
he's uh you know he he had a couple of
opportunities
right out of playing and they went so so
and he went and he sat on the bench as
an assistant
for a couple years in la and i'm fired
up for jason kidd
and i think he'll do a terrific job what
do you think um
you know obviously he knows the owner he
knows the territory he knows the
the place and franchise what do you
think he could do
if this is in fact gonna happen how can
he be the
the luca whisperer what do you think how
might that work
my my guess is that you know luca
probably had a little input that
they weren't gonna hire anybody without
checking with luca
i would assume yeah um
so and i and jason is a he's a terrific
communicator
um you know he luca his vision
so i know that jason's going to be able
he'll be on the same wavelength with him
i think it'll be a really good match
you know they've got some personnel
stuff that they have to shore up
but uh getting jason because i i think
it's a
terrific deal for them because if not
he's going to be coaching one of these
other openings
rex chapman here on the rich eisenhower
i did hear you on dp show earlier this
week right here on nbc sports on peacock
talking about kid
mentioning him when the subject of ben
simmons came up
yeah and and uh i i would love to give
you the floor on this certainly since
kid is in the headlines right now
and and so is simmons um about
about kids experience and how maybe
simmons can learn from it
yeah you know um when i watch ben
simmons play i
he's getting a lot of slander right now
and look i get it he's a he's a pro
being paid a lot of money to
play basketball he's never been a scorer
for us to think that he's just going to
become a scorer overnight is
outrageous i think i'm not sure that he
and joel can
will ultimately work together only
because they're also young
they need like for instance
uh we played with jason in phoenix we
had a veteran team myself
kevin johnson jason kidd danny manning
cliff robinson
and when we first got jason jason the
knock on him was that he couldn't shoot
um you know they called him mason
because he didn't
have a j
so we when jason would
when i'd come off the screen i'd have
jason's man and my man right in my lap
and you know i'd be like jay you've got
to shoot it make her miss you've got to
shoot it
and so we kind of
coached him up through that and then he
started making shots
and if i'm not mistaken he's like one of
the top three or four
made three-point shooters in history now
so it's going to take some time for ben
i hope that he's
able to kind of get over this because
you can tell it's messing with his head
he's a fantastic player he doesn't have
any other holes in his game
but this is something he's going to have
to tackle head on how did kid do it
did you have a front row seat to watch
it work what do you mean work
reps reps reps you know j j at every
level
high school college he
he didn't have to shoot he was so fast
he'd just get to the basket anytime he
wanted to
and um you know rondo when razon came in
much the same it took time it's going to
take time for ben but i know
the thing i don't know is if ben is
really
really being diligent about it jason was
and region was and that means thousands
of shots in the summer you know
hundreds a day and that that's what it
reps man reps you know just keep working
on you know doc
i mean you know doc knows this he knows
this so how
what do you what do you think it is do
you think he needs it's
who if you will get through to him or uh
or or that a change of venue is what
really might be necessary and
what appears to be taking place based on
woj's reporting that at the combine
uh sixers brass and rich paul of clutch
or chitchatting
about this subject right now yeah i you
know i'm sure that he's gonna be
talked about in trade discussions this
summer
um but man i just don't know he's so
young
so gifted um i i don't know that i could
give up on him that
that quickly and it'll be interesting to
see what kind of market is out there for
him
well i think there's going to be one
right i mean like who do you think would
where do you think a good fit might be
if we just extrapolate this out to the
summer
i don't know you've got to put him with
shooters you i mean you have to have
you know a team full of shooters
um can you imagine him on the bus
i'm sure the bucks could but and and the
blazers too right
right what about portland like i mean
you got lillard you got mccollum you got
the rest of that team shooting
but you got to give up somebody to get
him i know
i don't think it i i know we are just
playing fantasy basketball right now
right right but um and you have to go to
a place where
he's not hearing it from the crowd
that's why i think he's got to go
philadelphia is just philadelphia dallas
maybe so what porzingis you understand
the old the old uh unicorn back to that
division there's no way
that you could trade salmon for
porzingis no way i mean
no that doesn't work porzingis is not
that player not that kind of player i
know
right it just i i just trying to i know
that the dallas is
rumored to be wanting to maybe get out
of all of that it's just
i can imagine
no really i know right rex chapman here
on the rich eisen show
let's just uh remove the fact that the
hawks are up one games to none
and that the suns are up two games to
one right now rank
rank the four remaining teams with the
best chance to win
do you think in the to win it all rex
suns bucks hawks clips clips are last
huh
because kawaii's hurt or what yes yeah
i was at game one no one and
two in phoenix no just one just two
sorry
and the kauai thing i mean
kawhi is a top five player in the game
maybe top two
i mean he's so good and
removing him and obviously he's badly
hurt or
too bad to play in this series because
he definitely would have come back last
night right
um so i they're just not the same
paul has to carry a heavy heavy load
and then they've got to get guys who
last night did
guys like patrick beverly you know
making jump shots
they've got to slap two or three in a
night and that's not what pat bev
does he's a terrific player but they're
just limited
you know and the other thing where the
place that they're limited
is they have no rim protection i like
zubot he plays
really hard but phoenix just plays over
the top of him
they'd come off pick and rolls and just
throw it to the rim and play over the
top
and that's something right now that the
cliffs can't do they don't have really
anybody but paul
to attack the rack like that um
so yeah i think that uh i think they're
in trouble i kind of hope they're in
trouble
i know because i know i know you're a
son's guy
so um is that why you put the sun's one
is that heart and head together
or you just don't like what you see out
of the bucks and hawks or what
what do you got for me there well i was
i saw the bucks play
the brooklyn last week and i just think
that they're flawed
i i love chris middleton i love jew
holiday
but i think that giannis is so ball
dominant
you know they don't even pick him up
people pick him up in the paint
they don't even go out and honor him at
the top of the key much less the
three-point line
um and also sitting sitting courtside
seeing those guys
sitting courtside and watching phoenix
play phoenix
with chris paul in my opinion is the
most complete team left they
they have sides they have veterans they
have youth
they share the ball i mean the ball just
moves
they share the ball like a college team
and they love their coach man
they love monty williams that guy's come
in there and
you know you hear about culture change
all the time well yeah
he did it and those guys love him
they'll do anything for him and
it's a dangerous team how about that
valley oop man what was that like to see
in person
it wasn't real i mean that's the thing
about going
live sports man just going i've been in
you know i've seen thousands of games
played in
many many and still the other night
an ending we've never seen before
that we've never seen before i mean just
art it was
and then i caught myself several times
during the game looking around in that
arena
and just going man people this time
last year nothing we all missed this
i mean and it's just you know it's
community man it was fun
just really fun uh but that play was
unbelievable
what a pass right now if you know this
jay crowder
jay crowder's dad corey crowder played
for my dad wayne chapman at kentucky
westland college
and uh well i got to watch corey play a
little bit in college where he's a
little younger
yeah but what a he was division two
player of the year twice
and they won a title and he was a really
good d2 player really good
well after the jazz played for the jazz
for about a year that finished rex
you know that finish from everything
from the
the play call monty williams right the
the uh the pass where crowder had to
you know had to loop it over the
backboard pretty much
or avoid the backboard get it in the
vicinity of the rim for
ayton to not catch and jam but just
basically touch
a jam yeah and then but but the ultimate
was
the the screen on zubach by a guy who
had a broken nose in three places
right which you know there's a book the
reason that play works
is because they think devin may just
come right off of there
right and catch and shoot it was it was
a great pick
great pass i think i loved what i loved
most about it was i saw a couple angles
of jay
standing out of bounds and just you know
perfect
he let the play develop he's looking one
way and then
boom throws it completely the other way
and it's game over
just beautiful i do have to you know uh
i guess
is the phrase where it's stand for the
clippers and
say that you know replay gave monty
williams a time
out to draw that thing up for everybody
i mean
that that finish too what was that like
in the building half an hour
you know fans started grumbling and all
that stuff but it was just
it was so it was so enthralling i'm not
sure
you know people were into it and i gotta
say too pat
beverly that dude he
he should get paid extra for being
just that villain in every movie because
he plays
a great bad guy hate playing against him
you would hate watching him phoenix
every building can't stand him and he
relishes that
he relish it's funny to watch it it's
just it's comedy
it's entertainment the whole time just
watching patrick beverly you didn't
you you didn't like that role rex
and i kind of liked it i kind of like
this
i mean what's the what's the uh the
quietest you shut up in arena
rex chapman oh wow i don't know
college or pro where you took a shot and
and uh and it was game over yeah and and
when was the
when did you ever shimmy before taking a
shot as well
that was the other thing that that is
kind of different now every time
you do something now you're supposed to
have a little thing that you do right
i guess trey young's doing it i mean
but you know the first person i think
that i saw kind of mug for the camera
that i can remember
and it turned me off and then we ended
up being teammates and i forgot all
about it
chris webber fab five yeah yep like
he would dunk it and then he would like
look at the camera and
yeah what that was a whole new thing
i was like whoa whoa that's not part of
the game is it
and then he became your teammate and
it's like keep doing it yep
yep and i started doing it
so when did you ever do you have a good
memory of shutting people up like tom
uh i mean i can remember some game
winners and stuff but i don't
know i don't really remember the you
know the best
the best ones are just you know late
games
uh late games on a way on a way
uh set away venues where you know you
just make a dagger in front of the bench
and they gotta call a timeout and they
keep the whole crowd just cussing you
out it's beautiful
and then i guess well we're just before
i let you go on the subject of trae
young i'm fascinated
i i i get fascinated by people who take
who hear
uh uh opportunity knock and they don't
just answer the door they rip it off the
hinges you know
and and that's what he's doing right now
and i've i believe
i believe that he can make a shot where
whenever he wants
like you know and i know saying it's
like
lillard or curry is heresy when
somebody's just beginning to do it
but he also he's also dangerous in the
paint
so you know he can beat you off the
dribble he can create and then when he's
creating because of what he's doing
i think everybody else believes they can
make their shot too
it's infectious and i believe i'm
wondering what you think about the hawks
opportunity here i like the hawks i like
i love nate
of course played against him forever you
know what a great pro
nate mcmillan uh they've just got a
young you know and they're missing
uh you know missing a small forward
they're
trey young i i kind of try to pride
myself in knowing
on knowing players go and watch players
and being able to
tell who can play i couldn't stand trey
young
i was glad he didn't come to kentucky
and then
i thought oh my god i can't believe
they're taking him third in the draft
and i couldn't have been more wrong
could not have been more wrong
i'm i'm happy to say that i'm wrong
because what a fantastic player
the the other thing i think that is
discounted with him watching sometimes
just watching when he's running
without the ball he's a great runner
he's really fast he's faster than you
think he is and he covers
he's got a big long stride check trey
out
he yes he's small and he plays kind of
small because he doesn't attack the rim
but if he gets the other thing that goes
without that that
should be said he passes with both hands
equally well i mean he'll come off a
screen to his left
and whip a hook pass from you know one
side of the court to the corner in the
on the other side on the money just a
beautiful player they're dangerous
they're playing with a lot of confidence
much like the sun so hey i love how you
keep bringing it back to that
what where why weren't you sold on trae
young to begin with first blush
i don't know i don't know um okay
i historically and the game has changed
recently
for years and years i didn't like you
know i
didn't particularly like scoring little
guards
you know i just thought they well back
in the day
they would just get taken advantage of
defensively you know you had to find the
right
it's different now little guards aren't
posted up you know it's
you can't touch and hold and grab like
you used to be able to
quickness rules athleticism rules and
you've got all of that
so when you you said you used to not
like scoring little guards you didn't
tell that to
uh steph curry who was a guest on the
rex chapman show at mr josh hopkins
right
well he's not i'm talking little he's
six
three okay i mean we're talking you know
what's trey
six one plays like five ten
[Laughter]
well my social media grand maester tj
jefferson posted
after he torched his sixers uh that he
looked like the gerber baby
that they lost opie cunningham was how
he referred to kevin herder putting a
picture of ron howard up there next to
the gerber baby
saying that he lost the gerber baby and
cunningham
facts who's on charges who's on that by
the way congrats on
on the uh on the the the uh the
the charting of this podcast it's one of
the top sports podcasts out there
charges where you um have uh a guest on
to talk real life with what do you who's
next
who do you have man we just had uh i
just had
i don't know a lot about hockey but just
had chris nylen on
uh enforcer from back in the day with
the canadians that was magnificent
um next week yes
two-parter oh so yeah okay what are you
gonna do two weeks
okay i sat down for a couple of hours
with
yes stevie jackson and matt barnes okay
he got all the smoke he got all the
smoke well we're gonna release half the
smoke
and then the remainder of the smoke okay
so we're chopping up the smoke
that's right okay very good you didn't
inhale is what you're saying in the
first episode
right now you exhale
um so that's going to be i'm telling you
rich they
there are three or four of the things
that they said during this
that my mouth just dropped to the floor
okay
really good stuff and then uh you know
who's coming
shortly thereafter is jason williams big
jason williams oh really
okay well that will have you will have a
lot to talk about with that rex yes we
will
oh we will we're going to it's all going
good real really clean buddy
charges of course charges with rex
chapman podcast the rex chapman show at
josh hopkins podcast and of course also
at rex chapman
the block of charge is still going and
all the other beautiful videos that you
spread for some good love man you're the
best thanks for the call rex
anytime rich well duty back to you soon
whatever you want me right back at you
that's rex chapman
right here on the rich eisen show love
that guy man hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here